this video is sponsored by brilliant did
you know an oak tree is way more closely
related to a pumpkin than they are to
pine trees look here are the Oaks next
to the pumpkins and here are the pine
trees all the way over here before I
made this map I thought that all of the
trees evolve from each other but it
turns out the concept of a tree has
evolved throughout history multiple
times in this map of plants video I'm
going to look at all of the different
kinds of plants on Earth and how they're
all related to each other and I made
this video with the help of the experts
at the Royal Botanic Gardens queue here
in London and like all of my map videos
the post is available on my website dos
maps.com as well as all of our professor
astrocat books so if you want to get
your hands on it that's where to go in
this map I found the most sensible way
of organizing all the plants was by how
they've evolved so this map is really an
evolutionary tree of all plant life
based on our current understanding
and let's start at the beginning with
the most ancient Plants algae algae is a
name used to describe a wide range of
different unrelated organisms that have
the ability to generate energy through
photosynthesis but not all of these are
true
Plants algae come in many different
sizes from single cell varieties to
multicellular seaweeds in fact all
seaweeds are different kinds of algae
although algae aren't just found in
saltwater they can be found in fresh
water and on
land single celled algae known as
diatoms and the multicellular brown
algae are not considered true plants
even so they're very important to life
as three4 of the oxygen in the
atmosphere is made by tiny single celled
phytoplankton red algae are the first
big group of species considered to be in
the plant kingdom under the current
taxonomy containing about 6,000 species
although there's another small group of
around 15 species called glycophytes
which may also have Evolved first but
which one came first is still under
debate so what exactly is a plant
technically it's based on looking at a
part of the cells called chloroplasts
which do the
photosynthesis in Plants these
chloroplasts are surrounded by two
membranes which scientists think came
from an ancient event where one cell ate
another but the cell that got eaten
didn't die they started working together
and we Define all plants to have this
kind of double membrane chloroplast and
red algae and glycophytes have the
double membrane chloroplast despite not
having things we think are more
plant-like like leaves roots or a stem
the different colors of Ali come from
the pigments they use to convert
sunlight into energy green plants all
use two types of chlorophyll known as
chlorophyll A and B and these are the
same pigments used by green
algae repite algae are a distinct group
of green algae which are thought to
include the closest relatives to the
land plants the oldest fossil evidence
of algae and possibly all life on Earth
are found in 3.8 billion year old
structures called
stratales these algae were a kind of
photosynthetic bacteria called cyan
bacteria so these weren't plants but
green algae and land plants share a
common ancestor from 1 billion years ago
very early on in the evolution of life
on
Earth let's move on to the land plants
Brites contain mosses horn warts and
liver warts and are a crucial part of
our understanding of the evolution of
plants as they're considered to be very
similar to the earliest land dwelling
organisms on Earth which started to live
on land from around 470 million years
ago around 50 million years before
animals they La many of the features of
more modern plants like flowers or
vascular tissues which are the parts of
plants that transport water and
nutrients like sugars around the plant
but they do have root-like structures
called
riseo Brites typically grow in moist
Shady environments because they can only
collect water and nutrients directly
through their cells they love soaking up
any water around some mosses can absorb
20 times their weight in water they also
tend to be small typically around 3 to 6
cm in height because they don't have the
rigidity and structure that other plants
get from their vascular tissues the
maximum height they can reach is only 60
cm tall now every plant will meet after
this point has got a vascular structure
based on the fossils we've discovered
they first appeared around 420 million
years ago a vascular plant has
specialized tissues called xylm and flm
which transport water and nutrients
throughout its structures these tissues
are rigid and enable vascular plants to
grow taller and more complex and the
nonvascular plants we've seen so far now
we get to Club mosses and ferns Club
mosses aren't true mosses because they
have a vascular structure but also Club
mosses aren't ferns because they've got
a different Leaf structure to Ferns and
different DNA so they're stuck in the
middle here on their own ferns include
whisk ferns horse tails and
leptosporangiate ferns or lepto ferns
for short and these have many of the
features we're familiar with from Plants
Roots a vascular structure and and true
leaves called frons however they
reproduce through spores and not seeds
ferns are a diverse group with over
10,000 known species inhabiting various
habitats worldwide even underwater the
fossil record for Fern stretches back to
400 million years ago and the ancestors
of today's ferns were giants towering up
to 40 m in height the Earth was covered
in forests of tree ferns these have
mostly died out but some tree ferns are
still with us today a quick side note
for this map I can't physically include
every plant that exists so I've chosen a
familiar representative for each major
group of plants but from here onwards
I'm going to include the scientific
names that classify each group so if you
want to find where your favorite plant
sits on this map just look up its
scientific classification and you should
be able to place it from here on the
plants don't use spores to reproduce but
seeds this was a really important
animportant step for the proliferation
of plants a seed is made of a young
embryo some nutritive tissue and an
outer protective covering first let's
look at the gymnas sperms which today
comprise the major groups of sads Ginko
neum and conifers like Pines and spruces
these first appear in the fossil record
at around 390 million years ago
gymnosperms reproduce through cones
which come in male and female forms male
con cones produce pollen while female
cones contain ovules that develop into
seeds upon fertilization and these are
known as naked seeds CU they're not
covered in anything like a fruit or a
hard shell gymnosperms have
well-developed vascular tissues enabling
them to grow tall and thrive in various
environments for example conifers are
adapted to cold and dry conditions with
needle-like leaves to reduce water loss
and sturdy cones for seed
protection I just want to make a little
side note on fungi which which naively
seem like they're quite like plants but
actually they're very different they
don't photosynthesize and are
genetically closer to animals than
plants but they're very important to
this map because most plants live in a
symbiotic relationship with fungi called
micor riser in this relationship the
plant makes organic molecules by
photosynthesis and gives them to the
fungus in the form of sugars and lipids
while the fungus supplies the plant with
water and minerals like phosphorus from
the soil also when plants die fungi
break them down and return the nutrients
to the soil also lyans they're not
plants either they're a partnership
between algae and
fungi but I'm getting sidetracked now I
should probably do a map of fungi as
well anyway because of the close
relationship between fungi and plants
I've drawn a micro risal Network as the
background as it seemed
fitting from now on we'll be looking at
the angiosperms or FL powering plants
which first appeared around 135 million
years ago they're now the most diverse
and dominant group of land plants 910s
of the world's plants have flowers and
over 300,000 species of angiosperms are
estimated to live on Earth
today around 90% of flowers are adapted
to be pollinated by animals who have
also adapted to feed on the nectar or
fruit in a symbiotic
relationship pollen is the male
reproductive cell so basically plant
sperm and the female reproductive cell
is called an egg when they meet they
make an embryo which develops into a
seed in the plant ovary the ovary then
develops into a fruit which encloses the
seed this was a very successful
evolutionary feature to both help
protect seeds but also to disperse them
when animals ate the fruits and pooed
them out although this is just one
method there are many other dispersal
tactics on the outside of seeds like
hairs or wings to be carried by the wind
or hook to grab hold of
animals we also need to talk about
fruits because they're a little
complicated so anything with a seed
inside it is a fruit which is obvious
for things like plums and berries people
who say Tomatoes of fruits are correct
cuz they have seeds inside them but then
they should also include things like
cucumbers or pumpkins basically any
fleshy edible thing with seeds in it is
technically a
fruit nuts are also fruits hard fruits
containing in the seeds in a hard
protective shell which is formed from
the ovary wall Stone fruits like olives
mangoes and peaches have got a seed
inside the Hard pit in the middle and
beans and peas they're all seeds and
come in seed pods but we also have false
fruits like apples and strawberries
which don't form from the plant ovary
but from the top of the stem of the
plant so apples and strawberries aren't
technically fruits in fact they're
things that look like seeds on the out
side of strawberries are actually
individual
fruits and the word vegetable is a
generic term because some vegetables are
actually fruits like pumpkins but other
vegetables come from other parts of the
plant like potatoes or an underground
stem and broccoli is actually a flower
and kale or leaves okay back to the map
and now let's explore the flowering
plants we start with the early diverging
types of flowering plants those that
appear early in the fossil record and
which may give hints as to what the
ancestral flowering plants might have
looked like these include amberes which
is a small group is it only contains a
single species amberella
tropodo then we have NY Alis which
includes water lies and some other
aquatic plants then we get a collection
of families which include the peppers
where we get our black pepper but this
isn't the same as the pepper plant we
get chili peppers from we'll meet that
later then we have mag
Olas and Laurels also known as Bay trees
where we get bay leaves from and it's
what they made Laurel wreaths out of in
ancient Rome and
Greece these early diverging angiosperms
are examples of what the very early
flowering plants may have been like and
studying these is valuable for helping
to understand how different features in
the flowering plants
evolved now we get to a group called The
monocots which developed somewhere
between 140 to 125 million years ago the
monocots contain pondweeds
yams
pans
Lis orchids and
irises spider lies
Palms banana
plants
grasses and Brads like
pineapples I want to highlight grasses
because this group includes all the
cereal crops like corn wheat rice mazee
barley and loads of other cultivated
crops which basically make up around
half of human food and cover a fifth of
the earth's
land the monocots contain about 85,000
species but incredibly nearly half of
these are different types of orchid
which have got around 30,000 different
species and one of these gives us
vanilla monocots are one of the two
major groups of flowering plants
everything else will meet meet from now
on are on the other major kind of
flowering plant called
OTS the UDOT are the most diverse group
of plants today and appeared around 125
million years ago the UDOT are split
into three different subsections the
early diverging UDOT the rosids and the
asterids the name monocot and UDOT come
from how many leaves they sprout out of
the ground monocots typically have one
seedling Leaf when they first grow but
the Udi cots have two this seedling Leaf
is known as a Caledon so monocot is
short for monoc Caledon for single
seedling leaf and OTS are short for UDOT
Alon for two seedling leaves also all
UDOT share a distinctive type of pollen
which is described as triculate because
it's got three characteristic grooves
but a lot of the classification of
plants into these different groups comes
from looking at and finally combing
through their
DNA the early diverging Udi cots contain
buttercups which are also related to
poppies and
chatis proteas like lotuses and Banas
then we have gunas who have some of the
biggest plant leaves in the world which
can be as wide as a double bed then
there are mistletoes and then spiky
cacti whose needle-like spines are
actually hard pointy
leaves cacti are also related to the
carnivorous venus fly trap but
carnivorous plants aren't unique to this
group there are over 700 species of
plant that catch and kill animals they
typically live in environments with poor
boggy soil so they evolved many
strategies to get their minerals from
their victims by trapping and absorbing
them with fast closing Jaws or sticky
flowers or slick drowning pools that can
trap animals as big as mice and small
rats
then we have the saxifrages which
contain Stone crops peonies witch Hazels
and gooseb which have only recently been
recognized as being related based on DNA
evidence although it's still a mystery
how the saxifrages are related to the
other
groups the rosids appeared around 100
million years ago and their 90,000
species are now found all over the world
the major groups in the rosids are grape
Vines geraniums
fuches which are also related to pomeg
Grits then we have passion Vines which
are also related to poinas and violets
then wood
Sorels and Roses which are also related
to figs and cannabis then the legumes
which include peas and beans then Oaks
which are related to walnut trees and
then all the squash plants like
pumpkins then we have the hibiscuses
which are also related to the cacao tree
where we get get chocolate from then we
have the maples which are also related
to horse chestnuts and finally one of
the most important groups for our food
the brasas which contain mustard and a
single species of plant called Brasa
olaia which by artificial selection
humans have turned into cabbage broccoli
cauliflower brussels sprouts kale
collard greens kabi Gan and many more
new ones like purple sprouting broccoli
all from a single species from within
this
group so the Roos sits are clearly very
important for our food and interestingly
there are more than 880,000 edible
plants in the world but 90% of the food
we eat comes from just 30 plants the
other plants are either inedible or
actively toxic in fact there are more
toxic plants than non-toxic plants land
plants develop toxic chemicals as a
defense to protect them from getting
eaten mainly cuz they can't run away
also some plants use sharp Thorns or
spiky leaves like these Holly and others
like stinging nettles use stings which
act like hypodermic needles to inject
painful
chemicals with around 100,000 species
the asteroids are as diverse and as
widespread as the rosids the asteroids
appeared around 89 million years ago and
contain dogwoods and the related hyd
Ranger then we have roded endons which
is also where we find tea
and then we have the coffees which are
also related to gensin then forget me
nots mints then potatoes which are also
related to obene morning glories and the
Chili Peppers we also have holles and
carrots which used to be white and
inedible before being bred in today's
orange ones then we have ivis
honeysuckles and viburnums and finally
asteres which contain sunflowers and
dandelion and is where the name
asteroids comes from interestingly a
sunflower is not just one flower but
many hundreds of flowers called
florettes which each ripen into an
individual seed so that's the map of
plants video I hope you found it
insightful and a very special thanks to
the people at Q for helping me with the
research on this video and also letting
me film in their absolutely spectacular
Gardens if you've watched my channel
before you know I've delved into many
different areas but I can only ever go
so far in 20 minutes so if your brain is
hungry for more I can really recommend
the sponsor of this video brilliant I
love using brilliant to learn new
subjects using their fun interactive
lessons whenever I have a bit of
downtime and want to do something
productive with my brain for me I found
it a fun test of my understanding by
actually trying to solve problems which
has been shown to be much more effective
for people to learn a new subject
compared to just watching videos in just
say 15 minutes a day you can actually
properly learn physics mathematics
programming and many other subjects and
Brilliant does a great job at
customizing the content to fit your
level letting you solve problems at your
own pace where it's totally okay to not
know everything and make lots of
mistakes you can take a quiz when you
sign up and you'll be matched with
content that fits your interests and
level from very beginner all the way up
to writing programs for a quantum
computer which is actually one of the
courses I've been enjoying recently I'm
very lucky that I get to constantly
learn new things as part of this YouTube
job because it's so satisfying to expand
my knowledge and this is also why I love
using brilliant to try everything
brilliant has to offer free for a full
30 days visit brilliant.org
Doos or click on the link in the
description and the first 200 of you
will get 20% off brilliant annual
premium subscription thanks to you for
watching and I'll see you on the next
map video I've got some really good ones
lined up